les centaines de jeunes canadiens acquis
radio canada donne une voix pendant
cette campagne électorale ont interpellé
les candidats sur une foule de sujets
cette semaine la crise des migrants a
retenu leur attention surtout quant au
rôle que peut jouer le canada pour leur
venir en aide
des graines d'ailleurs les régions
pourront déjouer un mot quant à la
télégestion canada le bloc québécois lui
a répondu on est prêt à le faire des
mères aux organismes communautaires aux
citoyens il faut que le gouvernement
harper lève les obstacles nous
permettent de me démontrer nos valeurs
d'accueil
autres sujets marquants de premier vote
cette semaine l'économie après coûte
extrêmement cher à construire parce
qu'ils passent par dessus la mairie de
ces mystérieux la bohème avec succès
leur a permis de nombreux échanges
économiques avec bien d'autres provinces
québec pourquoi le québec devrait être
celle assumer la majorité des coûts du
pont champlain virus vih alors que le
pont profitent à toute l'économie
connaît la réponse du npd ne s'est pas
fait attendre
merci max ans chez nous pour ta question
je viends la position la question du
nombre de candidats dans les régions a
aussi intéressé les internautes
la première question en fête s'adresse
au parti libéral du canada
comment se fait-il que vous soyez le
seul grand parti qui n'est pas un
candidat dans chacune des
circonscriptions de la région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean
merci les parties mais randy canal va
présenter les revenants toutes les
constructions du canada chez toi ou
attaque saint-jean nos trois candidats
sont denis lemieux marquée du signe
il savait six morts dont 20 tous les
partis politiques sauf les conservateurs
ont participé au projet premier vote de
radio canada jusqu'à maintenant
d'ailleurs si vous voulez joindre votre
voix posez votre question à un candidat
sur instagram avec le mot-clé premier
vote
et si laurent terrière radio canada
montréal